let me just bring you some breaking news
now that's coming into us from liverpool
we understand that a 36 year old man has
been arrested on suspicion of the murder
of nine-year-old olivia pratt corbell
this is from merseyside police so let's
go straight to liverpool now and get
more uh shingi marike is there for us so
shinky what more can you tell us
that's right anna the police have
confirmed that they have arrested a 36
year old man in connection with the
murder of olivia pratt corbell they say
that the 36 year old man is from the
hoyton area he was also arrested on two
counts of attempted murder the arrest
came after an operation involving armed
officers in the merseyside area last
night so thursday 25th august and that
the man is currently in custody being
questioned by detectives of course this
is a case which has really shocked the
nation the shooting of a nine-year-old
girl and the safety of her own home and
we now know that the police have made an
arrest that a manhunt was on the way and
they were asking people in the area to
come forward with information and break
that wall of silence and come forward
and talk about what had happened to
olivia on monday night we now know we
can confirm that the police have
arrested a 36 year old man